hey what's going on it's bill burr and
it's time for the thursday afternoon
just before friday monday morning
podcast and
[Music]
just checking in on you just checking in
on you
just hanging out on a thursday morning
getting ready to go do all my [ __ ]
it's april 14th everybody
you know what that means tomorrow
you have to do your taxes
you have to uh
put in for an extension
you have to get the money back that you
gave to the government
in the form of an interest-free loan
people i'm going to get outside my
element right now and i'm going to talk
inflation
what's the deal with inflation
why does inflation happen
why will it continue to happen i'll tell
you exactly why because people pay
attention to the colors of ties
these [ __ ] liberal snowflakes with
their goddamn
[ __ ] inflation
[ __ ] other yeah these red tie sons of
[ __ ] with their uzis and their ar-15s
all your [ __ ] dumb [ __ ] why don't you
wake up
become smart like me someone who doesn't
watch the news someone who is isn't
informed
someone took
45 years to consistently spell
restaurant correctly
someone who still can't spell vinyl
i know there's a y in there
wait i got it v-i-n-y-l
is there an a in there
whatever you need to listen to me man
it's vinyl bill not find that yeah
now she used to watch a show called
vinyl i still didn't know how to spell
it
yeah
inflation is because our currency
is controlled by a private group of
bankers that have created basically a
legal ponzi scheme
okay
might also have to do with the fact
we've been playing a road game for over
20 years that bankrupted the [ __ ]
country
that might also be what it is but i
don't want to get involved in that
because then everybody gets upset
because they'd rather [ __ ] blame the
color of ties
and pay attention to uh jokes told by
stand-up comedians that's what's
destroying the fabric of america
it's not doctors creating synthetic
heroin or people poisoning the food
supply or dumping water into our [ __ ]
dumping water dumping poisons into our
drinking water
it's not the government allowing on both
sides allowing these corporate [ __ ] to
create disposable [ __ ] made out of
plastic that then is dumped in the
[ __ ] ocean it's not any of that
it has to do with blue ties
and red ties
oh billy's on his [ __ ] preacher stump
today isn't he
um
anyway
the end of the day
until we get rid of at least 80 of the
population
probably even more like the longer we go
the more drastic the culling of the herd
is going to have to be
in order for the surviving human beings
to just chill the [ __ ] out
and let the earth try to write itself
this is what i would do if i was
getting rid of the herd
all right
i would keep all the astronauts
and i'd keep all the nerds
and then what we do
is
we create these giant
space garbage trucks that's right i said
it space garbage truck if trump can say
nuclear is the real n word i can say
space garbage trucks and probably win a
local election
dude i like what this guy's talking
about with his space garbage trucks this
is what you do
you vacuum up
space garbage trucks into vacuuming the
ocean bill that's right
it's two and a half times the size of
texas and [ __ ] two miles deep you
vacuum up all of that [ __ ]
and you stick it in these space garbage
trucks and then you fly them out
i don't know where they go the
astronauts come back we'll stick monkeys
in them
monkeys
all right and then if you're part of
peta and you're like oh the monkey
didn't [ __ ] do anything man we're
going to say well go save them
you thumbed footed [ __ ] you go do it
right and then when they jump on the
space garbage truck we just we launch
and that's it
you know what i mean
like what the [ __ ] are we doing right
now
the whole thing's going to hell in a
handbasket and everybody's acting like
you know nothing's going on
and they're still screaming and yelling
at either side
i don't know
and then meanwhile red bull is gonna
[ __ ] fly two cessnas side by side and
see if guys can get out of them and
switch planes
you mean i gotta be honest with you what
this has to do with that [ __ ] drink i
have no idea
because i don't remember [ __ ] you
know evil knievel being connected with
[ __ ] you know
root beer
or pepsi
ladies and gentlemen this is the caesars
palace pepsi challenge
um
can somebody please explain to me what
the [ __ ] red bull has to do with some of
the best pilots in the world that's what
i want to know it has nothing to do with
it i don't i don't think that either one
of those pilots is going to be like you
know what's gonna make this [ __ ] jump
successful
or this flight successful
so here's the thing with that stunt
it's really not a stunt
this is me with 300 hours
it's really not a stunt unless neither
one of the people is wearing a parachute
other than that
you know
what are you doing
this is what you did
like the [ __ ] nerve of me with my
summer school education to [ __ ]
question this the physics involved in
this thing they'd have to weigh the
exact same they'd have to be flying the
exact same speed
and then there has to they have to be a
certain closeness right because the
second thing nose them down
the thing that i would be concerned
about
is if you you can't fly it faster than
terminal velocity or else the second the
humanoid gets out
he's not going to be able to keep up
with it right
oh billy lab coat over here
i don't [ __ ] know
but what i do like is that they're gonna
do it out over the ocean
because
god forbid
if it doesn't work we kill human beings
the polluters of the ocean
let's just make sure that if it doesn't
work
that there's people there to fish out
the two humans that just dump two
airplanes into the [ __ ] ocean to
continue the pollution
let's make sure that we fish them out so
those two people can tell the story and
continue to buy [ __ ] that they don't
need that's gonna end up in the ocean
um sorry
anyway
having said that i'm going to watch it
i am going to watch it i'll tell you
what i watched yesterday
vladimir guerrero jr
putting on a [ __ ] display
in the bronx
against the uh i can't really can't
really call them the bombers anymore
even if they hit a lot of home runs
they're playing in that [ __ ] wiffle
ball park
it's really weird how the ball carries
there you know
um
anyway the guy gets up right
gives the old right there fred hits a
[ __ ] home run
he's playing first base
it was sort of a bad throw he reaches
for it and as the runners cross in the
bag vlad's hands almost down on the
ground and the runner steps on it
with his cleats there
the plastic tips on him that will then
or metal tips i don't know evidently
though what they'll end up in the ocean
at some point float next to one of those
red bull planes
right
he cuts his [ __ ] hand
his finger
doesn't get stitches
just gets his finger taped up and what
does he do
he goes reggie jackson he puts three on
him
right there fred right there fred
and right there fred
now granted
this doesn't make you reggie jackson
cause this man does it in october
all right
however
the toronto blue jays
you know
are talking all kinds of [ __ ] saying
last year was the movie trailer this
year is the movie
to which i say
oh yeah
so now i am rooting for the devil rays
and the red sox and even the yankees
even the yankees
to shut those sons of [ __ ] [ __ ] up
because a long time ago i remember there
was an interview with getty lee
of rush
and he was at a [ __ ] blue jays game
and he was talking [ __ ] about red sox
fans as if
he wasn't a four-eyed nerdy bass player
from a prague rock band as if he was
gonna throw down
in the bleachers as if he wasn't sitting
in the box seats
you know
listening to the umpires clicking
little machine there keeping track of
balls and strikes and thinking in his
head oh that sounds like a good baseline
to me
ever since then
i have been like [ __ ] the [ __ ] diaz
brothers and [ __ ] the toronto blue jays
having said that vladimir guerrero jr is
a [ __ ] problem
but [ __ ]
the toronto blue jays
you know
that's where roger clemens went and
started air quote working out
i don't know what's in the water up
there in toronto
but that doughboy was done in boston and
all of a sudden he goes up to toronto
cue the super friends music when they
get out of the trap
back to sai young's
he came back like hulk hogan when they
went to drop his arm for the last time
and it came back up
yeah everybody says he did roids that's
not what happened he grew a goatee and
he put icy hot on his balls and the rest
is all history that's a [ __ ] true
story
all right
no i'm happy that the blue jays are good
man that's always good for [ __ ]
baseball especially up in toronto
it'll be sunny out something good in
sports will be happening
other than the usual disappointment
of their beloved toronto maple leafs
year in
in europe people i'm turning 54 years
old in june
54. 54 is the exact year
between
that the rangers went between stanley
cups
1940 to 1994.
okay
the toronto maple leafs
have not won since 1967 my entire
life plus one year
the last time they hoisted the cup
old freckles where was i religious
people
you tell me where the [ __ ] i was
all right and i'll go sell you a
footbridge in [ __ ] albuquerque um
sorry i'm in a mood right now
i'm in a mood
um
no because i have all this [ __ ] work
ahead of me and i got to be honest with
you last night
i went out and i was hanging out with
the buddy of mine
who gets mad at me when i don't say his
name on the podcast and i say well i try
not to say names he goes
i love if you'd say my name
so in case he's listening
this goes out to you
i was hanging out with a buddy of mine
last night
[Music]
and i smoked a cigar even though i was
trying to go 10 days after the masters i
was just stressed okay it's the only
thing i have left
so i [ __ ] um
i go up to uh
i go out there
my buddy's like you're doing a set
tonight and i said no i'm not i'm just
gonna [ __ ] hang i got to talk to you
man about editing this movie man i need
to hear your [ __ ]
thoughts on it man
um and of course we barely talked about
that we just sat there making fun of
each other
and um
anyway so i say goodnight to him and i'm
driving home
and as i drive home i go by the comedy
store and i was like [ __ ] this i gotta
go in there and i went into the comedy
store
and uh
try it out you know not just you know
the [ __ ] i've been working on and it
could not have gone better and i was
literally i was over the [ __ ] moon i
was so happy when i got home
i couldn't fall asleep till like 1 30 in
the morning
right then of course my daughter comes
in and she's waking me up right
just sitting there like dad can you make
me french toast
and i was like okay
she said thanks and then my wife goes
um we still have leftover pancakes
and i said oh that's right and then my
daughter goes oh
and that's how it begins
that's how it begins it's like
you know
my kids don't realize that like
four out of the seven days i make them
sunday level breakfasts when i was a kid
you had [ __ ] cereal for breakfast
all right
cereal the whole week and then on sunday
my mother would either make eggs
pancakes waffles of french toast
and it was [ __ ] amazing
there's bacon
toast and all of that [ __ ] it was
[ __ ] incredible but for the rest of
the week
you know
it was corn flakes it was cheerios it
was apple jacks occasionally fruit loops
they didn't last long
um
i remembered i used to like eating boo
berry or count chocolate count chocula
but always felt like [ __ ] afterwards
so anyway i had a great day yesterday
with my daughter right we're hanging out
and i you know
she's like uh i want let's do daddy
daughter time so i'm like all right
and i go okay what do you want to do i
have to run a quick errand she goes all
right she loves running errands like
just going places
and uh then she goes i go what do you
want to do she's like
you know i want you to take me to get
ice cream
so i'm like all right so we go to get an
ice cream
and i'm hanging out with her and it's
just like magical the stuff she's saying
to me and she's like a little girl now
so i'm literally it's like phone off
or at least to the side let's not be
let's be honest here i didn't shut it
off i headed to the side and i was just
sitting there talking to her
and she was just saying all of this
hilarious stuff
and she was in a great mood and all of
that
and she telling me that she loved me and
i was the best dad ever and all of that
if you ever want to hear that stuff get
your kids some ice cream it's literally
the bill cosby bit that is great
give us the chocolate cake same thing
right
so um
yeah she told me that she loved me and
how awesome i was and all of that stuff
and within two hours of that
you know we were playing cards we were
playing war and she wasn't winning and
she was getting so mad
and she was like cheating we were like
we got into a war and i see her she puts
the three down and then you know from
one pile and then on another pile she
pulls out an ace to win it
and i'm laughing i'm like sweetheart you
can't do that she can't do that she goes
you don't make the rules
i was like yeah i didn't i didn't make
the rules the rules of this game were
already established before i played him
and she kept she got so mad at me within
two hours of telling me that she loved
me she said dad
we aren't best friends anymore and i'm
never getting ice cream with you ever
again
it's unbelievable
i'll tell you
that that female brain it's real fickle
i'm kidding it's not male or female it's
just
was adorable um and i was cracking up
laughing which was making her even
madder
um but i also noticed something i don't
know if other dads have this my son and
my daughter beat the [ __ ] out of me i
have so i somehow [ __ ] up because i
like roughhousing
that
now whenever they see me laying down
they run over to me and they essentially
do hulk hogan's
second reference to him in this podcast
hulk hogan's finishing move
remember that he'd leap up in the air
and [ __ ] and slam that leg down except
they go like ass first
right onto my rib cage
and uh it's fine if i see it coming
but one day i was laying on the floor
and i was tired
it was the middle of the day the sun's
out right so i just had a pillow over my
head
over my eyes
my eyes right i had it over my eyes and
my daughter came in and leapt up in the
air my i was totally relaxed i didn't
tighten up at all and she just landed on
me
and i'm not gonna lie to you i had to
regroup
i literally rolled over and brought my
knees up and i was like buddy buddy you
can't do that you can't do that she
started crying because she realized she
actually hurt me
i mean think about that it's like
somebody just somebody just lay in there
and you're sleeping somebody came in and
just dropped a 40 pound 50 pound bag of
sand
right on your stomach i mean there's
only one response to that oh
that's what
then what's funny is they get startled
and they get upset and you have to
comfort them
as you're trying to get your win back
um
i'll tell you what is awesome though is
we got my daughter an electric car for
her uh birthday or for christmas i can't
remember what
and um
i play this game
we call it playing target right
like you're going to target you have to
park in the parking spot and i just put
two hockey sticks down and she has to
back the car in there and she has my son
my son in the passenger seat and now
when she backs up she literally puts her
arm around the seat the passenger seat
where my son's sitting and she's looking
over her shoulder and she's starting to
figure out how to drive back like that
it's just one of the most exciting
things
it's like she's gonna know how to drive
a [ __ ] car
by the time she's six
um
amazing all right true bill we got to do
some advertising here true bill do you
know why do you know why free trials
renew without your consent yeah because
they're pieces of [ __ ]
that have paid off the better business
bureau
um it's a business scam out to get you i
absolutely love this true bill thing i
stand by this
not because i'm the original true bill
because i speak for my heart because i'm
a brave warrior
um
social justice person
i love this thing because i hate these
pieces of [ __ ] that do this that renew
your things without your consent other
than directv that renews all my sports
packages
without my consent automatically i love
that because
i'm going to renew them anyway and now i
don't have to do it but these other
[ __ ] things are ridiculous all right
don't let greedy corporations
pocket your money
download true build to take control of
your subscriptions truebill is a new app
that helps you identify and stop paying
for subscriptions you don't need you
don't want or let's be honest you simply
forgot about on average people save up
to 720 a year with true bill yeah [ __ ]
these people get true bill because
companies make subscriptions hard to
cancel true bills makes it incredibly
simple just link your accounts and true
bill will cancel your unwanted
subscriptions in one tap
this is like you're a mob boss all of a
sudden you just you just call up some
hitmen and they go out there and they
whack who you need to be whacked
um and your true bill concierge
is there when you need them to cancel
unwanted subscriptions so you don't have
to truebill has over 2 million users and
helps save them over 100 million dollars
like matthew b
who said in a matter of seconds i've
saved 660 dollars for the year on my
directv bill saved 120 for the year on
my serious xm bill saved 840 a year on
car insurance
jesus christ this guy was shelling out
all kinds of cash that's fourteen
hundred fifteen hundred sixteen hundred
twenty dollars matthew b save don't fail
don't fall for subscription scams start
today at
truebuild.com go right now truebuild.com
yeah it could save you thousands a year
truebill.com
like how is that even legal
automatically renews
[ __ ] heartless greedy [ __ ]
all right oh look who it is everybody
look who it is it's all zip
according to the latest research 90 of
employees plan to make enhancing the
employee experience a top priority in
2022
after all a happy workplace is key to
attracting and keeping employees and if
you need to add more employees
to your team their zip
their matching technology helps you find
the right people uh for your roles fast
and now you can try zip
that was the evil version uh for free at
ziprecruiter.com
zippercue recruiter uses its powerful
technology to find and match the right
candidates up with your job then it
proactively presents these candidates to
you you can easily review these
recommended candidates and invite your
top choices to apply for your job which
encourages them to apply faster no
wonder zip
is the number one rated hiring site in
the us based on g2 ratings zip
recruiters technology is so effective
the four out of five employers who post
on ziprecruiter get a quality candidate
within the first day find the right
employees for your workplace with
ziprecruiter try it for free at this
exclusive web address ziprecruiter.com
that's
com
ziprecruiter.com
burr b-u-r-r one more time zip
near france yeah
the smartest way to hire i like that one
you like the devil version of it
raw see you soon
i remember used to hear that on all your
[ __ ] um
all the records when i was a kid
they would always start it off
with some backwards
horseshit you know just to get the kids
to play it the other way
it was so dumb like how we didn't
realize that that was just a scam to get
us to buy records
you know they're putting these secret
messages in there they're easily decoded
you know it was more like when they
would do it backwards
within the song that was the smarter
phony pretending that you were actually
demonic
i thought if you asked me
if you actually buried it in the song
and i loved that they thought
that like somehow the human brain
can hear you [ __ ] bro she like him
like
while you're listening
to don't need nothing but a good time
raw [ __ ]
you know
you're gonna go kill your parents
and then you know these bad parents
would end up blaming that
hey you know it wasn't that i wasn't
around as a parent i mean when i was i
was drunk and i used to beat my kid with
a belt that's not why he went out and
did these horrible things the reason why
is when he was listening to heading out
to the highway buried within that song
was somebody saying
and it actually made it to trial
actually made it to trial you know why
that is
oh jesus
because this country was founded by a
bunch of murdering lunatics that did it
in the name of god
there you go how about that now i want
you to stick that next to your gas
prices
huh
and [ __ ] light up your pipe and see
what happens i don't know what any of
that means it sounded good though
you know that's always great to you if
you say something then tag it with us
once you stick that and you pipe and
smoke it
it always makes the listener think like
wait a minute
i
i swear to god i didn't think he said
anything there but now he just told me
to take what he just said stick it in my
pipe and smoke it
i at the very least have to think about
what he said
was it profound or was my initial
reaction that that was just a bunch of
[ __ ] correct
i don't know
i
do not know
um
all right anyways that is the podcast
here for thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast i am so in
on baseball it is ridiculous
and uh if you're a red sox fan
all right
um
watch the red sox next week
because i think i might be back in town
and i might be going to a game
all right
and i am putting in for
the local celebrity seat
all right no i'm kidding i'm good
i'm gonna be up in the bleachers
you know
it's really gonna kill me do they still
have that [ __ ] mascot
um
it's really annoying that
alcoholics that understood sports get
replaced by [ __ ] fuzzy
those [ __ ] things walking around i'm
really against that okay we shouldn't
have alcoholics in the stands scaring
the children okay
i'll go with that but i don't think you
have to over correct it that i now have
to look at [ __ ] elmo walking around
the park like a complete
[ __ ] jerk-off
trying to get peace people excited about
free trinkets all right that's something
else all right and with that
um please listen to the music here and
followed by the music will be a bonus
episode of the thursday afternoon just
before friday monday morning podcast
from a thursday afternoon just before
friday monday morning podcast
from uh thursday uh
back in time all right that's it go [ __ ]
yourselves good luck to the red bull
people put some icy heart on your balls
get out there and uh don't buy it
whatever it is don't buy it you don't
need it
and then eventually you have to get rid
of it you don't need any of that [ __ ]
all right
um god bless you and uh the united
states of america
[Music]
hey what's going on it's bill byrne it's
the monday morning podcast for monday
april 14th to thousands of flat day
uh jesus christ i've been sitting here
uh i'm still uh in france this is the
last [ __ ] week i'm in france
um last couple of days here so that's
why i'm still using the garage band
thing and it sounds a little weird but
i've been sitting here for [ __ ]
a half hour
waiting for the lovely nia to leave the
apartment so i can do the goddamn
podcast she's probably going to come
back here in the end
but uh
i just i mean does anything take [ __ ]
longer i know this is a hacky bit and
it's been done a zillion times but every
comic out there wears a [ __ ] sweater
and works totally clean and ah guys do
this and women do that but
does anything [ __ ] take longer
than a woman getting ready to leave
i actually had to die and laugh and she
grabs this [ __ ] bag and the amount of
[ __ ] she's putting in it i was like are
you going on an excursion
she had medicine in there
she grabbed like [ __ ] three different
things to put on her head or around her
neck scarves [ __ ] whatevers
i don't know why does it take so long
um
i just kept saying get the [ __ ] out of
here
um anyways
so
i don't know what the [ __ ] i'm gonna
talk about this week because i haven't
been doing [ __ ]
i haven't watched [ __ ] i haven't talked
on a cell phone in forever um
i'm completely out of the loop
like i finally just checked in with the
nhl
nhl.com to see what the hell was going
on
oh and by the way
if you lived over here
uh you would you would get into soccer
or football
uh
you'd get into rugby
you'd watch all those sports and you'd
enjoy it they're great games that's what
i realized once i've been over here
[ __ ] long enough
and at some point you have to watch a
goddamn sporting event
you know
and uh
you go in there and everybody's into the
thing and you just you just get sucked
into it
like i'm i'm actually rubbernecking now
when i walk by screens and there's a
soccer game on and i never you know i
don't watch that [ __ ]
um
and late last night i did catch
uh
the ending of the masters i think bubba
watson won i hope he did
i saw when he birdied and he went up by
three
and then i checked in on
the internet when he had two holes to
play and he seemed like he had it
um
but i promised my wife i would come back
here and watch i swear to god
the devil wears prada
you know
trying to keep the peace i agree to come
back and watch this [ __ ] film
and uh
i gotta tell you it was worse than i
thought it was gonna be
i figured if meryl streep is in it
you know it's got to be good on some
level
watch that movie or somebody somebody
can somebody actually i don't want to do
this
to a guy is there a woman out there that
can do this can you somehow cut that
movie
down to how many times
a scene starts with one or two people
walking fast into the scene
that whole [ __ ]
the whole ridiculousness of fashion in
general and these [ __ ] people walking
in okay i need six dresses i did and
all that and like i couldn't watch the
movie because
within the first three minutes
i'm yelling at the screen
to meryl streep's character you know get
it yourself your silver head [ __ ]
right so knee is punching me
and it she was just so ridiculously mean
in that movie that after a while i
didn't have any sympathy for the big
brown eyed girl
who sat there getting abused
so finally after like a half hour i
start like nodding off
granted i got a couple of beers in me
you know
oh more than a couple okay i've been
drinking this [ __ ] over here 1664.
it's hilarious with typical americans
need to sit and they go was that the
year of the french revolution and the
only reason why i knew it wasn't was
because i just
you know being in france you stumble
across some [ __ ] about that again i
think that was 1789 so we looked it up
to see what the significance was
and it was just the year that the
brewery started
so anyways i've been knocking those
things back those have been my core's
light over here the 1664 whatever the
[ __ ] year it is
and anyway so i lasted about maybe
45 minutes into it the dude from
entourage is in it
and they didn't give him anything to do
the poor bastard
all he had to do was just sit there and
be like what she was being a [ __ ] again
can i make you some food you look hot i
want to [ __ ] you that was his scene
every [ __ ] time you saw him um
so anyways
you like i'm reviewing this movie that
came out i thought like three years ago
i guess it was like 10 years ago
but uh so anyway so i pass out
slash falls and right before i go to
sleep i i say to nia and go wake me up
when she tells this woman to go [ __ ]
herself and she goes okay i will and she
didn't
you know
i guess why would you why would you wake
up somebody who finally nodded off
who's been calling one of the main
characters the silver-haired [ __ ] i
understood a decision
you know but the next day i woke up i
said so what did she finally say to her
and she goes actually she didn't say
anything she just sort of walked away
what a horrible movie
um
oh anyways uh where we're staying
the guy who runs the place is from uh
he's from london
and he was talking about some that woody
allen movie that had won an oscar
i was downstairs he goes did you he's
like did you say that
i go yeah yeah i saw it
and i go yeah i liked it i thought it
was great and he goes you thought was
great
because
i thought it was absolute rubbish
i love when english people say that
rubbish it was absolute rubbish
it didn't go anywhere it's like
it movie starts the woman's crazy and
i can't do the english accent he
basically said in the end of the movie
she's still crazy he goes i thought a
movie's supposed to lift you up and take
you somewhere said the movie didn't take
you anywhere i had to admit i i couldn't
argue with this criticism of it i still
liked it
ah jesus what am i [ __ ] siskel and
ebert over here
um i got nothing to talk about people i
really don't so as i was mentioning i
checked in
with the uh
with the nhl to see what was uh what was
going on and lo and behold it's time for
the playoffs
so having not watched any of the [ __ ]
for weeks now
i'm gonna give you my picks
these are my picks all right
first round we got the bruins
here we go bro wins here we go
first the detroit red wings who are now
in the east for those of you who have
been sleeping
um
yeah i don't know i think i'm going to
go with the broads on that one
then you got the [ __ ] hated habs
against the lightning i'd take the habs
i think pittsburgh's gonna beat the blue
jackets and i like the flyers to beat
the [ __ ] rages
um over in the west the best thing about
the west if you're a fan of a team from
the east is that they're all going to
beat the [ __ ] out of each other and only
one's going to be left in the finals
that's the only thing i can say about
that because
they look [ __ ] strong out there i'm
going to say
minnesota
in an upset over the
abs unfortunately i don't think st louis
is gonna get by chicago
and pulling for those guys to finally
[ __ ] make a run
uh anaheim's gonna beat dallas and i
think the kings are gonna beat san jose
and those are my picks with absolutely
no information behind him i have not
watched a hockey game in two weeks
so there you go
no information behind those picks
i'm picking them like a [ __ ]
like a chick well you know what that
means most of those will probably come
in
don't don't put any money on it because
i don't i don't want to deal with that
so you're probably asking yourself so
they're [ __ ]
french freddie what the hell did you do
this week
i continued butchering their language
i picked up some new new expressions
or a couple of words
uh an old platt means a flat water
uh excuse me
[Laughter]
you know what's funny too i noticed the
way they said they don't say we they say
way
like way and then that means like yeah
so if you say we that's like you going
yes and then they immediately know even
with that one word that you're a tourist
forget about your [ __ ] bruins
hat that you're wearing
if you know if they say would you like a
beer and you go yes instead of yeah
yes i would like a beer mister thank you
if you please
but they've been cool as hell
so anyways
um
i actually went out to uh omaha beach
this week and i i got to tell you
something um
if you ever get a chance you gotta do it
it was
uh you know what it's not really
something you can i can express in words
it was
it was uh unbelievably moving
it was iconic
um
i i i don't i don't know where to start
oh we set up a private tour
because i i can't stand
i hate group tours because when you go
on group tours you know
aside from seeing fat people in jean
shorts
there's going to be that douche
who like has read up on this subject and
is actually going to try to out nerd the
nerd given the [ __ ] tour
and you know which all it does is just
drag the tour out
like you know i mean
i'm into it but i don't need to hear
every [ __ ] nookie nook and cranny you
know
just give me
the [ __ ] bullet points give me the
highlights
all right
and with that if i want to go deeper
into this [ __ ]
i'll do it on my own
you know but you know there's going to
be somebody standing there dressed like
some civil war reenactor right
just that [ __ ] so i don't want to deal
with that and uh
and then also if you have a question you
don't have to wait for anybody else
[Music]
so that's basically why i choose
uh to do it like that so basically you
show up
and uh the driver takes you we stayed in
uh is it bayou obey you i don't know
where the hell it is
i don't know how you say it
um
oh this is [ __ ] hilarious so i rented
a car
um once again control freak i don't want
to take a [ __ ] shuttle out there with
another 20 douche bags i don't
all right
so and we rented this car one way
from uh we took the train from paris up
to bayou
and uh it was amazing just an amazing
ride you know beautiful scenery and that
type of thing unless you're looking at
somebody's house then it's always ugly
houses near trade tracks are always ugly
because basically what you're seeing is
the backyard is somebody who can't
afford to not live right next to the
[ __ ] train tracks but when you get
out of the towns
uh the scenery is beautiful
um
so we get out it uh
by you or whatever it's what i'm gonna
call it pay you by you whatever the [ __ ]
you call it and i go to the uh
the rental car place and now we're in
the [ __ ]
okay in paris you run into people that
can speak english we're [ __ ] out
there and you know for the most part
nobody speaks
any english and when it was actually fun
i kind of learned
what my wife does when she talks to
people
like she doesn't understand most of what
they're saying she just looks at what
they're doing
and at some point they'll give away kind
of betray basically what the [ __ ]
they're saying
and what it is is not freaking out and
you kind of gotta sit in the pocket and
wait for them to point at something
do some sort of shoulder shrug
because you're renting a car
which you've done a zillion times
so you know what happens if they
basically say hey how are you
and you're like hi my name is so-and-so
i want a car and then they'll say the
next thing is do you have an id or do
you have a reservation number you kind
of know the series of questions and
there's just something about uh there'll
be either one word that you pick up
or just something that they they point
or something like i asked this woman
where the bathroom was
we went out to this [ __ ] jesus christ
we went out to this
i don't know what you call it what do
you call it when people just take their
old [ __ ] and they just
they all go to the same dirt parking lot
a bizarre
a market
we went to this [ __ ] market so
the great thing about this market was
they had it in the same place in the
middle of the country
every [ __ ] week
and uh so somebody built like a little
restaurant up there where you could go
drink was the greatest market i've ever
been to right sitting there waiting
around all this
[ __ ] but i gotta tell you my wife fine
thumbs some gems in there but i just
don't have the patience
it's just sitting out on a damn table it
just looks like [ __ ] to me so i went in
and i had a couple of beers and this
woman didn't speak any english and
finally i asked her uh
you know
toilet
and she's still looking at me like what
and i'm like jesus christ i can't even
convey that to you the [ __ ] toilet
cebu play right
so uh
she starts going a mile a minute
in french and i'm like i'm [ __ ] i
don't and she's pointing out the door
and i have no idea what she's saying and
then she kind of does this
loop around sort of motion with her hand
and i'm like oh it's outside and around
the [ __ ] corner and lo and behold
there was
wc water closet that's what they call it
they call it a water closet
because that sounds much better than uh
than a [ __ ] shack whatever the [ __ ]
you'd call it right so i go in there
and uh i didn't have my phone on me i
really wish i could have taken a picture
i basically
you stand on this porcelain thing and
there's a hole in the ground you just
pee into
it's like these two porcelain
like
things you're supposed to stand on i'm
like i'm not [ __ ] standing on those
things
so i stood behind the porcelain thing
and i got a little arc going
you know like larry bird in the
three-point contest just one after
another going right in the hole
and you know i missed the last 10
seconds um anyways
what was my point oh so anyway so we go
to we go to obey you by you whatever the
[ __ ] you call it
and um
oh yeah so that's right so i'm renting a
car
and this is something that i've known
i've noticed now that is international
anytime
you rent a car one way
that location is gonna give you the
[ __ ]
that car that nobody wants to rent
it's gonna be a [ __ ] up color it's
going to be a [ __ ] up model something
about it you know what these people
rented
uh we went
with two people that's all we are they
gave us this giant
mercedes van
that like a nine passenger [ __ ] van
and i'm driving through
these little european streets with this
thing
with like two pieces of luggage all the
way in the back and i know what you're
thinking well bill it's a mercedes this
is what you don't realize about mercedes
is they have a lot of low-end [ __ ]
underpowered cars that they don't send
over to the united states
a lot of those uh i think just they just
feel they can't compete with honda's
toyotas and i don't know whatever the
americans are putting out
or what but this thing was an
underpowered hunk of [ __ ] with the
mercedes emblem on the steering wheel
and uh i was turned i can't tell you how
many [ __ ] times
i clipped a corner trying to drive this
bus around the corner
so um
long story short i'm driving this giant
[ __ ] partridge family mercedes-benz
truck
down the damn street we get to our hotel
uh
everything we you know everything's
great
and um
we take a quick cat nap and then uh this
guy shows up this guy from scotland
and he took us on this unbelievable tour
of basically um
omaha beach in this other area some
point i already forget the name of it
and this guy was an absolute
maniac
absolutely obsessed
with world war ii and obsessed
with d-day
and he had all these photographs
that he had he'd blown up from other
books and was talking about
misinformation
and it was an incredible tour
the first point of the tour you actually
like the pill boxes and stuff you know
where the germans had their machine guns
or it was a little barracks or was a
place to keep their ammunition they're
still there
you know the guns aren't there but
basically where they were is still there
and you get to walk into these things
like on the ground where these cement
bags that germans had put you know when
it's rained and you know and it all
turned hard and now like you can't even
if you look at them actually look like
rocks they look like white rocks but
they're actually bags of cement and you
just look in there going like a german
soldier set those [ __ ] things down
and then all the events happened and
here they sit seventy years later it
gave you goosebumps
and
um
this guy knew all the history he goes
this is where private so-and-so came in
he threw a grenade you can see the
shrapnel
on the wall and you're looking and
there's the [ __ ] shrapnel
we walked into this one bunker and right
to the right was a little like probably
just enough for someone to stand
and it had like uh and it was about two
inches below the floor that you were at
as far as like where the floor was there
and it was a little shower and
our tour guide said hitler got gassed in
world war one so he made sure
that all of these bunkers had showers in
case because i guess you know such a
horrific experience for him
you know that he made sure like none of
the troops were going to get caught out
there like he did
and uh it was this really bizarre
like human moment
from one of the most evil people on the
[ __ ] planet it's like wow that guy
actually did something nice
[Music]
so there you go people he's not all bad
when you walk into a german bunker
he made sure they all had a little
shower
so there you go
there's there's one good thing
he still has six to nine million
you know
bad things
in in the other uh part of the ledger
but he does have that one thick
i bet that was the thing after he blew
his brains out if there is an afterlife
and god was giving him [ __ ]
i
i bet he just kept coming back to that
but but but i wouldn't i put
would shower i did not have to do that
[Music]
ah you know he lost his temper and
started yelling at god
you know god just sat there shaking his
head but part of him had to be like i
made this
what the [ __ ] was i doing on that day
and then he just presses that little
button under his desk
which is why would it be under his desk
like what's he nervous he's running [ __ ]
he's like the dawn of all dawns
i bet he just let him talk
sit there stammering
dancing around sweating before he
[ __ ] opened the trap door
um
anyways
what am i talking about here let me let
me do a little bit of advertising
and i'll get back to this [ __ ] here and
i apologize for the sound of the
clicking i know this is annoying but
what do you what do you want from me
well bill we'd like a professional
podcast well then you know what listen
to a professional podcast don't listen
to this one all right hulu plus everyone
you've probably tried hulu on your
computer hulu plus is so much more with
hulu plus you can watch current seasons
season episodes of your favorite shows
like modern family the daily show and
scandal and watch every epis episode of
shows like nashville lost and doctor who
basically all the big ones that
everybody watches you get ad-free movies
and kids show two kids shows too now
more than ever there is so much to watch
take total control with hulu plus to
stream these shows and thousands
of
what and thousands more
as much as you want
wherever you want hulu plus works on
your computer your smart tv
smart tv what the hell's that roku apple
tv xbox playstation pretty much any
streaming device you already own you can
even watch on your iphone or ipad while
on the on a tran
at work at the dentist or in the
bathroom you can even block off a day to
binge
um you also get access to
hulu originals that you can't get
anywhere else check out the new show
deadbeat comedy about a pot smoking guy
who talks to ghosts
i want to watch that binge on all 10
episodes starting april 9th for only
7.99 a month get any shows you want
anytime anywhere that's like a quarter a
day people right now sign up at
huluplus.com bill or click on the banner
on my website and get two weeks full
access completely free that's a whole
extra week more for this special offer
when you sign up at huluplus.com bill so
get with it and start streaming tv now
with hulu plus
um all right next one up here e-voice
everyone
what you want your business to make more
money e-voice can help
here's how when your customers call
you'll have your own toll-free number
professional greeting dial by name
directory and more you'll sound like a
fortune 500 company and really stand out
from competitors evoice lets you give
out one number that rings wherever you
are you can be at your kid's soccer game
you'll never miss a chance to grow your
business evoice uh
evoice even takes
all your your voicemails transcribes
them and sends them to you instantly as
a text or email so you can check your
voicemails before the meeting ends and
not even look rude evoice is only 13
bucks a month and right now my listeners
can try evois for free for 60 days
that's right a 60-day free trial don't
put this off turn down the radio get to
a computer and set up your e-voice
60-day free call now so you can see what
i mean go to e-voice.com promo code bill
that's evoice dot com promo code bill
all right you know i hate when they do
that shut off the podcast right now
the [ __ ] i'm doing you guys
a solid here reading your ad then you
tell them to shut off my podcast you
know what they did you know they sat
there in their little
what are their advertising cubicles
you know they just sat there going like
well the problem is is they hear the ad
and then they're listening to the rest
of the podcast and by the time the [ __ ]
has that there yeah
well what if we told them to turn it off
now go [ __ ] yourself all right so
anyways
so um
back to the
tour so we're walking in out of these
bunkers and um
oh my god ain't even on the way there
this tour was so good like they had all
like those uh i guess english people
call them hedgerows
you know back in the day to mark your
property
you grew these giant like
rows of bushes that i forget what
they're called but they
the guy actually let us get out and
touch some of them they had like these
these thorns on them that would just rip
you to shreds
and um
you know they were like seven eight feet
high and could be upwards of eight feet
across
there was no way to get through them so
i know in that saving private ryan they
showed a little bit of the fighting that
was going on but you couldn't even see
through them even today most of them
you couldn't even see through them so as
you're walking up the road right on the
other side of you could have been an
entire you know
i don't know what do you call a platoon
a division of germans
uh
it was absolutely insane so they used to
send patrols out they'd hack a little
way through it and they would send a
patrol
into these fields
and i guess the rule of thumb
in war which i you know i i i don't know
anything about it is they never sh they
never shoot at
a patrol
because then you only get like three
four guys what you want the patrol to
think is that it's safe and then they
wait to
the entire company
basically marches three quarters of the
way into the field when they have
nowhere to hide they would just mow them
down and the germans would put like just
a couple of nests machine gun nests
could handle
each one of these fields i mean it just
seemed like
after you got off the beach you're
thinking like okay now it's going to get
a little easier and it's just
it was just a
it was a [ __ ] show basically so anyways
um
so
we saw the initial uh
area whatever the [ __ ] that was called
and then he's taking us down to omaha
beach and i i gotta tell you it was like
you know it's great it's a famous beach
you look at it and it's undeniable
that's omaha beach
and this guy broke down the uh
the entire thing you know i didn't even
feel worthy of like walking on to the
beach
it it had like that level
of effect on me which i i you know i
did i didn't know what i was going to
think when i got there but it was um
it's incredible he shows you the
pictures and then he starts pointing out
on the bluffs where the germans were and
and how few that there were
but i guess the bombing run we [ __ ] it
up we didn't do it right
on that one where we did it much better
on the other beaches utah and all that
but we uh i don't know
i don't know it was it was uh
if you if you can somehow get over here
and do it
you know all you got to do is just get
the plane ticket you can stay in a
hostel
have a banana there's your [ __ ]
breakfast
jump on a train and go out there i
highly suggest anybody who's
ever thought about doing it uh you will
not be disappointed and then in the end
um the end of the tour he takes you up
to the cemetery
uh
the american cemetery it's just it it's
unbelievable it's unbelievable and they
play taps at the top of every hour and
right as we got there
you know probably there for like three
minutes
and you're looking at all of all of
those graves all of those people that
died
trying to stop this maniac
and uh and then they play taps i mean
it's
overwhelming to say the least
um
and then of course there's also the
english cemetery
which a lot of americans don't know
because we watch the american movies and
they make it seem like it was just
the americans who were over there uh as
always but you know something you know
what
the [ __ ]
this english guy downstairs was laughing
giving me [ __ ] about how all the
american movies
like even argo he goes you know uh the
english and dutch helped you guys out
with that and i go well you know you
guys will make your movie then and he's
laughing i'm like you guys do it too
because i'm one time i was on opie and
anthony
the great opium anthony radio program
with little jimmy jeremy norton
and these guys came in from england and
they had made a documentary about uh the
late great
beast of a comic bill hicks
and they were talking about how
bill hicks went to england that's where
he had to go to get his his buzz going
and then came back and took america by
storm and he's sitting there saying
he said
this one of the documentary guys
was going
uh
and while england was listening to bill
hicks people in america were busy
wasting their time listening to
listening to carrot top
and
i forget if i said it on air or not and
i wanted i was it's like dude you
realize that you're in america right now
you do realize that so if you're gonna
spin these yarns like
i was alive during this [ __ ] time is
is that what i was doing and i'm not
[ __ ] on carrot top either i think
the guy's funny
but like i was like oh i thought i was
listening to carlin and uh
sam kinnison i thought i really liked
sam kinnison
and uh evidently i didn't
uh you know
everybody does that [ __ ] you know we did
everything and we understood
and these guys were idiots so uh
so [ __ ] you england
you know you do the same [ __ ]
anyways
[Laughter]
oh
i've been over here too long i'm not
gonna lie to you as fun as this is this
is the most relaxed i've been in forever
and uh but i am ready to go home and i'm
ready to go back to work
i'm ready to start telling jokes again
and i miss the hell out of my dog
i'm literally walking around um
every dog i see was was staying in this
[ __ ] uh
uh st tropez
or as the locals call it santropay
uh yeah i know you're like jesus christ
bill
i know this is the vacation to end all
[ __ ] vacations i haven't taken one in
forever so whatever i'm blowing some dvd
money over here
um and i gotta tell you something
we're actually here it's it's this
summer season starts literally the day
after we leave so it's kind of cool it's
a lot of locals and people are just
starting to trickle in
and
do you remember that 50 cents uh do you
call it a song
is it called a rap is it called a ditty
a p diddy i don't know what the [ __ ] you
call it but you remember that one where
i i teach you how to stunt
and for people out there as white as me
which means i basically
show you
um how to blow all your money on
depreciating assets and make yourself a
target every time you drive down the
street
i believe that that's what stunting is
um
[Music]
well you walk around with a chain that
has a dollar sign on the end of it made
out of some precious metal that's a
smart thing to do
um and before all the uh racist people
out there think i'm just talking about
uh african americans i'm not i'm talking
about anybody that's
new to money like that's what you do
uh but these people out here
rich old white dudes
they do the same thing but in a much
more subtle way
they show off their [ __ ] wealth it's
[ __ ]
clear first of all
these french guys out here
the heads of hair on these sons of
[ __ ] is incredible and they all have
this same haircut it's like basically
uh how would i how would you describe it
it's the
it's like the hockey
mullet but with a page boy quaff at the
end of it it almost curls back into
itself and then they they push it back
it's like a mullet
meets
uh remember remember jackie stewart
the formula one race car driver they all
have that irish spring [ __ ] cut into
some soap with the knife in the 70s
haircut
and
they have their beautiful wives
and they have this sweater draped over
them
with the [ __ ] like and then they have
like one piece on them
be it a watch
glasses but it's only one
it's one thing
that just says
i have more money than [ __ ] god
and then the rest of it is just really
neatly put together
um it's called having class people
you know you don't sit on the hood of
your new car holding up handfuls of cash
and use that as your [ __ ] facebook
page that's what people do who just got
money and always wanted money these
[ __ ] here
these frogs with their [ __ ] money
these guys
it's it's ridiculous and and
and then every once in a while and oh
there's nothing i like
is their cars
they're they're whips
what i like about these guys because
they're they understand money and how it
works
um
they a lot of them
bought some top of the line car like 20
years ago and just kept it in impeccable
shape
like i saw this guy he had basically
like the 1993 version of the mercedes uh
what's the top end big one there
the sl [ __ ] whatever 550
s550 he had the 1993 version of this the
thing pulls up absolutely immaculate it
looks showroom brand new
and he parked it and he got out
and i uh was able to ask him in broken
french
what year the car was um
would i say kellage blah blah blah or
something like that
and he just beamed with pride and he
said 1993
and i was like treviane and he's like
you know it was just you could he you
know he knew obviously it was some
stupid american try to talk to him but
he he i was really [ __ ] cool just
i've seen a couple people over here
they don't just buy out a flashy car
like they [ __ ] love their car and
they keep it really nice i saw like a
like a 1987
um bmw like m5 that was look like in
showroom condition
um
so you got that level of wealth
you know what's funny too is mia has
just been trashing me because i refuse
to buy any i'm in san tropez clothes and
i'm walking
in my sweatpants
and i got this
hat that i got at that mario the mute
thing
and i look like an [ __ ] i'm not gonna
lie to you i i mean i even like go to
walk out i see my dad jeans that i'm
putting on i i really look like an
[ __ ]
um i don't give a [ __ ] i'm gonna sit
there and buy some salmon colored shorts
right some dumb sweater to drape over my
[ __ ] shoulders
um
anyways
uh
so you sit down along the [ __ ] water
and just one giant goddamn boat after
another is sitting there
and i'm trying to think like how much
[ __ ] money would you have to have
this guy this guy's got a [ __ ] boat
down there i swear to god it's gonna be
like a seven million dollar it's a yacht
he's got a flight this guy he this guy's
boat was so [ __ ] big i'm sitting in
the cafe and i'm i'm looking across the
street
across the sidewalk and into the back of
this guy's boat
and i'm watching
i thought he was one this is [ __ ]
hilarious i thought he was watching a
karate movie on his tv he was actually
watching dancing with the stars
it shows you what what is what has
happened to karate movies
they've become too crouching tiger and
not enough hidden dragon if you know
what i mean you know
i'd like to see a little more mark for
death
in my you know my movies and judah
freelander always told me mark for death
introduced the breaking of bones
into martial arts movies anyways
uh yeah so basically i'm sitting there
and i'm watching this guy's tv on his
[ __ ] boat from a cafe across the
street that's how big this boat was
that's how big that [ __ ] tv was
and it's just been parked there all week
or docked whatever you say
and um
at one point i'm coming back into town
to buy my 900th [ __ ] cigar of the
week
and i'm looking on the boat and i see a
guy it's a chef
on the boat
dressed in like you know i'm going to go
cook a gourmet meal and i'm just saying
how much does that guy cost a year
right
you got to give at least 8 500 grand a
[ __ ] year
to just be ready at any no point like to
jump on your boat and make you a [ __ ]
sandwich
and i i just want to [ __ ]
learn how to say permission to come
aboard in french
and i just want to find like how did you
make that what did you do
how the [ __ ] do you have that level of
money
right is that nuts sorry and i hope i'm
not boring you guys with this [ __ ] oh
but anyways let's get back to the
bayou thing
um
we ended up going to this museum
when we were there that had all this
video and all these pictures and that
type of stuff and what was really cool
was um
i'd never seen footage like this i think
a lot of it was
you know french footage
and first of all their museum was way
more inclusive
like it had
it had the the the uh
american troops british troops canadian
troops
and french
the french troops and everything you
know a lot of people like you know
break the french balls
you know my impression of a french
soldier and you just put your arms up
like you're surrendering i guess
it took
the germans like about five six weeks
to take over france and in that time
um france lost 90 000 troops
not like casualty like dead
that's not even just the wounded so they
put up a hell of a fight but and i gotta
be honest with you if we live that close
to the germans we would have [ __ ]
lost
okay and we wouldn't need somebody to
bail us the [ __ ] out too
and i know right now you go give me a
[ __ ] break it's like [ __ ] you
okay to this day
look at their top end cars look at our
top end cars they're still kicking our
ass
i know the cadillac and i know the
corvette that's probably the best we
have
but it's nowhere near what they were
doing that was another thing that was
great on the tour they were talking
about how much better their weapons were
so when we [ __ ] kill a german we'd
pick up their machine gun
because this [ __ ] was better than ours
we basically
we just we [ __ ] wore them down
we just come we came up
what happened how we finally took the
beach on d-day you know what is they ran
out of bullets
we just kept coming
this [ __ ] they call this guy the the
butcher of omaha beach
he was in this position
that was they put a gun into the back
corner of a hotel
and he was just [ __ ] you know doing
what verzi wanted to do with the you
know with this goddamn i don't know what
the [ __ ] millimeter he had
and he went through seven hours of
ammunition in [ __ ]
three hours
by the end they were shooting like
that weaponry where in it
every third bullets of flare
and that's how we ended up knocking out
we finally could see where the [ __ ] they
were i mean it was just
what happened on that day i you can't
even [ __ ] put into words and to have
a [ __ ] like me trying to explain it
um
i i just i i can't even imagine it i
can't even [ __ ] and as much as like
the beginning of saving private ryan
shows it like just to actually just
rather than watching some video or movie
of it to just be standing on the beach
and this guy's telling you the stories
showing you the pictures dude it was it
was unbelievable unfucking believable
so
anyways um
i got water in my ear
i've had it my [ __ ] ear and i've
tried every goddamn thing i've tried
blowing a hair dryer into my ear i've
tried jumping on one foot
i tried sleeping on my side
it's great it's basically just gradually
drying up
and uh i'm really hoping when i get on
the plane my ear is not going to [ __ ]
with me
me actually was going on the internet
looking for [ __ ] everything like as
i'm losing my mind
i feel like i'm trapped in my own head
that's how many how much water was in
there
and they were doing this [ __ ] make a
suction with your own hand none of that
[ __ ] works
so
she finally reads that you go to the
pharmacy and you get some uh
alcohol
and you you squirt the alcohol in your
ear and i don't and i'm just like i'm
gonna put more liquid in there
so i just decided to wait it out but
it's been driving me [ __ ] nuts
anyways
let's uh let's bang out the last couple
of uh
does anybody have like anybody know
anything that you can do
to get water out of your ear before i
get on a plane and start screaming as
the air pressure changes
as they pressurize the cabin
um
anyways
here we go legal zoom everybody
modern technology is great smartphones
ipads and other gadgets make it easy to
do so many things but why is it that our
lives seem busier at the same time i'll
tell you why because you got to download
the new version of everything
all right that's not part of this read
well when it comes to getting the legal
help you need legalzoom provides a great
solution that works with your busy
schedule let's face it the legal system
is complicated there are better things
you can do with your time thankfully
legalzoom is there for you so if you're
thinking about starting a business
forming an llc or getting a trademark
will or living trust legalzoom gets the
job done right
you'll get the personal attention you
need and they'll help you take care of
all the details legalzoom's been helping
families and small business owners for
over 14 years and they received an a
plus
from the better business bureau call or
visit legalzoom today for an extra
discount enter bur burr in the referral
box at checkout that's legalzoom.com
discount code bur legalzoom provides
legal help through independent attorneys
and self-help services but it is not a
law firm go to legalzoom.com enter the
discount code bur b-u-r-r and last but
certainly not least the classic
stamps.com everyone computers are
designed to make running a business
easier including your mailing and
shipping just use stamps.com to get
24-hour 24-hour access to the post
office right from your computer no
waiting in lines no hassles man
stamps.com makes mailing and shipping
easy just use the computer printer you
already have to get official us postage
for any letter any package print the
postage directly into your envelopes
onto your envelopes labels even plain
paper then hand it to your mail carrier
that's it there's no guesswork
stamps.com will send you a digital scale
that automatically calculates the exact
postage you need for any class of mail
you'll never have to go to the post
office again i use stamps.com to send
out all my dvds and posters i'm a [ __ ]
if i can use it so can you right now use
my last name bur b-u-r-r for this
special offer no risk trial plus 110
bonus offer
that includes a digital scale and up to
55 dollars in free postage don't wait go
to stamps.com before you do anything
else click on the microphone at the top
of the home page and type in bur burr
that stamps dot com enter bur
all right
back to the uh back to the podcast here
um
oh by the way
everybody over here it seems either
drives a [ __ ]
scooter or a goddamn motorcycle
and uh to the point we actually think
it's safe but the dude downstairs is
telling me they have more more damn
accidents over here than anybody else
but then i'm also thinking well you got
more people on scooters
than anybody else and you got a ton of
[ __ ] money over here
so you know what that means that means
you basically you can go out and go buy
yourself a bike that's way beyond your
capabilities
right
it also means that you have a complete
disregard for 99 of human life
like most rich people do you have a
sense of entitlement you're going to
ride your [ __ ] scooter in your
motorcycle like that that's what i'm
saying
why am i saying that because i like
riding motorcycles every once in a while
and it scares the [ __ ] out of me that
something bad's gonna happen so what i
do is i just justify it away in my head
the same way i do when i smoke a cigar
going i don't smoke that many of these
[ __ ] things
you know it's what you always i'm not
going to get cirrhosis of the liver
this plane isn't going to [ __ ] all of
a sudden make a left turn and then
nobody can find it
that's what you do to get through life
it's what you have to do
ah she's not gonna divorce me and take
me for everything i got
i'm sure it pussy's clean
you know it's only four chocolate bar
i'll hit the treadmill tomorrow
isn't that what you do
the [ __ ] you just justify it
rather than sitting down going no this
is a dumb thing to do this is going to
make me fat i need to wear an extra
condom i should probably just go jerk
off
you know
maybe if you don't call somebody a
gray-haired [ __ ] during all the chick
flicks maybe she won't divorce you and
take all your [ __ ]
right
you could do that that's that's called
being an adult
i think it's about time
you
all right
talking to you right now the listener
it's about time you guys [ __ ] growed
up
you understand me
i'm getting so [ __ ] sick and tired
now kid
um
anyways oh hey last week
um
me and uh the lovely nia
had a uh one of our classic debates
which is
basically
the two of us talking over each other
and then yelling stop interrupting me
like most healthy couples do
um so anyways last week
uh for those of you who didn't listen uh
what happened was some what was
this guy sent an email and he was
basically saying that the woman he's
been dating for the last six years when
they got together she was beautiful had
an amazing body and now she has a new
stressful job and she's put on like 60
to 70 pounds
so he's talked to her about her weight
he said he's concerned he bought our gym
membership he's trying to get her
healthy meals he packs her a lunch
he's going out of his way to try and
help her out and uh evidently she's not
going to the gym and he found
some fast food wrappers stuffed under
the seat of her car or something and um
he's like what am i supposed to do and
nia flipped out on the guy and i
defended the guy all right
and then
the listeners you guys you guys all
chimed in not all you but a lot of you
sent me emails and a lot of people gave
me props
um for am i allowed to say that as a
white guy
gave me um compliments
for staying in the pocket
and not allowing myself to be railroaded
and then they also criticized mia saying
you know to basically show beautiful
intelligent could just oh still only
hear what she wants to hear
and i would throw that right back at you
right back at you
it would be amazing that you can see her
doing that and not notice that you're
doing the same thing just as a guy
you're doing the exact same thing that
you're giving a [ __ ] about
you know
basically what happens there when you
have a story
between a man and a woman in a
relationship is you just insert yourself
into the story so as a guy who would you
be
you be the guy who had the hot
girlfriend who now put on 60 to 70
pounds
and now has as the guy said
has sloppy tits
as a woman you listen to the story
and you listen to i have a stressful job
i'm putting on weight
i'm doing the best i can and the person
that i love just said i had sloppy tits
so her reaction and my reaction were
completely normal all right it has
nothing to do with intelligence it just
has to do yeah it's like a fender bender
right
you know how [ __ ] we are you blow
right through a stop sign and t-bone
somebody
and when you get out the first thing
you're gonna say is what the [ __ ] were
you doing
yeah that stop sign was great
you're gonna come up with some line of
[ __ ] so um
whatever you know the deal everybody
just [ __ ]
you know people hear what the [ __ ] they
want to hear all right
and they respond to it so i don't give a
[ __ ] either way god bless you for
listening but you know you don't have to
say
the i mean i don't mind just saying oh
she was being ignorant or whatever but
someone sometimes you know the little
yeah you get a little disrespectful the
level of derogatory
that you [ __ ] you take it to you know
because you can be anonymous
as you sit there in your cubicle or
maybe you have an office maybe you're
the office guy
right and you got that little [ __ ]
thing there
you know those marbles at the end of the
the metal things and you you throw on
the pendulum
and you [ __ ] swing it and click clap
click click click click right
just ticking away the seconds of the day
whatever that [ __ ] thing's called
if you own one of those how soon before
you get the giant globe
in the corner
that's something a hipster would do
you know what i really don't like about
hipsters which is a really hacky thing
to not like half the [ __ ] that they make
fun of they don't even understand
like uh
i've noticed a lot of hipsters they like
they they're obsessed with tail fins on
cars they think they're so cheesy that
they're [ __ ] awesome
you know and they don't even understand
the function of like back in the day
with that technology you needed them
tail fin basically kept the rear end of
the car
at high speeds on the ground
so you could have more control and you
wouldn't get [ __ ] killed not granted
if you put a tail fin
on a [ __ ] car that's never going to
reach those speeds yeah it is funny but
a nissan maxima i mean that thing could
get up 120 miles an hour right
it should have had a tail fit
in the early 90s
and people enjoyed it they liked them
they looked cool
so you stuck them on your car even if it
didn't need one the same way you put
rims on
i don't know get me [ __ ] started with
that [ __ ] um so anyways i'm probably
gonna cut this thing short this week
because uh my internet connection is
really horrific out here to the point
i'm gonna have to send
this podcast in sections because uh i
got a bad feeling if i try to send the
whole thing at once that i'm gonna get
three quarters of the way through my
internet connection is gonna crap out of
me and uh
that's going to be my day trying to send
this [ __ ] thing so um
that is
that is the podcast for this week
um
i hope you enjoyed my little travel
[ __ ] diaries
i don't know next week i'll i'll be back
you know
so au revoir go [ __ ] yourself that's the
podcast for this week uh next week
i'll be back home and i'm really ready
to go home i want to see my dog i want
to watch some hockey
you know
i want to eat that american food that
makes you fat i can't tell you something
i've been eating like a [ __ ] animal
over here and i barely put on any weight
all right i don't know what kind of
poison is in our food over there in the
states but i'm telling you i am eating
like a [ __ ]
well you know something over here you
kind of nibble but you're doing it the
whole day
like all the lunch places close at two
o'clocks and then you have cafes and
they're always bringing out some sort of
pastry or some [ __ ]
yeah jesus christ listen to me sitting
in a cafe eating pastries what the [ __ ]
happened to me i gotta get back to the
states um i will be back next week and
the podcast will sound
at least semi-professional i appreciate
you guys toughing your way through these
things
and uh like i said once again if you
ever get a chance
to uh go visit omaha beach you gotta you
gotta do it you definitely gotta do it i
highly recommend it all right that's it
go [ __ ] yourselves i'll talk to you next
week
you